donner plus de visibilité pour les
prochaines semaines c'est l'objectif
affiché par emmanuel macron alors que la
circulation du virus progresse sur tout
le territoire avec à ce jour 22
départements classés en zone rouge alors
ce conseil de défense est d'autant plus
important que la direction générale de
la santé a indiqué hier soir lors de son
point quotidien que le nombre de
nouveaux cas de contamination ces
dernières 24 heures constituait un
record depuis le début de l'épidémie
alors emmanuel macron pour tenter de
ralentir la progression du virus va
devoir décider de décliner les mesures
territoire par territoire localement
faire quelque part du sur mesure un
local avec deux villes qui devraient
être au coeur des discussions lors de ce
conseil de défense
bordeaux et marseille à ce jour on
compte 280 contamination pour 100000
habitants dans la cité phocéenne alors
un autre point qui devraient être
abordés lors de ce conseil de défense
c'est la question du dépistage puisqu'on
l'a vu la stratégie actuelle du
gouvernement a montré ses limites avec
la hausse des contaminations mais aussi
les files d'attentes interminables
devant les laboratoires ou encore les
délais à rallonge pour obtenir à les
résultats des tests un changement
devrait donc être opérée pour que les
passions qui montrent des symptômes
soient testés en priorité et enfin les
effectifs de l'assurance maladie devrait
être renforcée pour permettre de
remonter plus rapidement les fameuses
chaîne de contamination
voilà quelques points qui devraient être
abordés lors de ce conseil de défense
qui a débuté aux alentours de 11 heures
avec un enjeu capital pour l'exécutif
éviter à tout prix
1re confinement qui aurait des
conséquences désastreuses sur l'économie